all right super bowl lost 31-9 to the
tampa bay buccaneers they
were prevented the chiefs were from
winning two in a row patrick mahomes
addressed yesterday
motivation that comes not from winning
the super bowl
but from losing it here he is the first
year that i started we lost to the
patriots an afc championship game i mean
you have to
let that stuff motivate you to get
better each and every day and so um
you look back at that and we were able
to find a way to kind of flip a switch
and make ourselves better and make a run
at super bowl the next year and you have
to try to
have that same mentality of knowing that
we've been there two years in a row now
we've won one we lost one we had to find
a way to get back and try to win it how
much have you watched of that super bowl
game going back and watching the tape
and is there anything that you've taken
away from that game that you've kind of
incorporated into your off season plans
as far as getting ready for next season
and
brad one quick follow-up if i can yeah i
mean i've watched it i think two times
kind of watched two times and kind of
moved on from it i'm sure i'll watch it
more in the
virtual off season that we we have going
um
just just having to continue to take
what's there i think there was times in
the game where
maybe we were down in the game and i try
to scramble and make a play happen
when i didn't have to um they were
playing a lot of deep coverages and i
probably could have handed it off on
some of the rpo type options that we had
um and then at the end of the day we
just got to execute at a higher level as
an offense um and so uh i know the guys
are motivated to come back
and do whatever we can this offseason
whenever that is
um and to make ourselves uh the best
team we possibly can
i'm surprised he watched it twice that's
nice i'm getting myself to watch it once
right wouldn't you yeah that's that's
that's not easy when you lose a game
like that
you know you've worked so hard to get
there and you lose it that way it is
it's gut wretching to sit there and
watch it back
it really is it's it's the worst thing
you can do as an athlete and that
big playoff whatever national
championship
you know one and done type of deal to go
back and watch those games uh yeah it is
brutal
you hate to relive it and go through it
all and you know good for him for
watching it twice and learning from it
this dovetails with what we discussed
yesterday as it relates to trevor
lawrence the chip on his shoulder or
lack thereof
the adversity that he has yet to face
because he's lived
a charmed football life so far you do
have to
find motivation in your losses
in your disappointments that's what
patrick mahomes is doing that's what
he's learning and you do get motivated
more
by being thrown off the top of the
mountain than by
being able to plant a flag in the top of
it that
that's natural that's human nature and i
think that through the adversity that
trevor lawrence undoubtedly will
experience at some point in the nfl the
question is
how much of that becomes the fuel right
to keep pushing to keep fighting because
you're competing against as we said
yesterday others who are motivated by
those same things and at the end of
every year there's always going to be
31 teams whose players are motivated by
the fact that the season didn't end the
way they wanted it to
yeah no i mean you're right i mean this
this is this is going to be some
challenge this year for the kansas city
chiefs football team
it is you know first off we're going
into the fourth year in a row where it's
like whoa
deep play-off run everybody ex you're
you're the the biggest show
in football basically i mean that
happened mahomes first year as a starter
about three or four games in
they became the hottest ticket in the
league and whoa we got a sema homes the
chiefs
this is unbelievable afc championship
game two super bowl games
now you know how deep can they go in the
playoffs you know once again
they have tremendous self-confidence
that's the one thing about the chiefs
that always jumps out to me
the belief in you know themselves as a
player
and then their belief as a team that
they can get it done no matter who's out
there against them whatever that may be
uh but this will be some sort you know
tough challenge him coming off an injury
you know them being the king and knocked
off the pedestal
it's been three tough football seasons
you know did
the the human tendency to just take your
foot off the gas a little bit does that
happen this off season
you know i don't know but i was real
confident last year
going the chiefs will be back in the
super bowl like i you know i was saying
that pretty early on
this year i don't know after a loss
i'm not sure if i feel the same way i
know they'll be there and
and in the mix of things but i'm not as
confident just to say they're going to
be back in the super bowl
we saw the patriots eight straight years
get to the afc
championship game and when you get to
that level
some years you get to the super bowl
some years you'll win it some years you
don't get to the super bowl right right
the pay the patriots set that template
for eight years the chiefs
have made it for three years i think the
real challenge for this team now chris
is is growing as an offense
right beyond what we saw in super bowl
55 because there were flaws there
yeah can they figure out how to address
those flaws so patrick holmes
isn't running what was it 525 yards
behind the line of scrimmage before he
threw the footballer got sacked right
in super bowl 55 with that bad toe what
are they going to do
to balance out the offense maybe maybe
run it a little bit more maybe they need
to do that maybe maybe this is the old
andy reed flaw
rearing its ugly head that even with
patrick mahomes you can't be so skewed
toward the passing game
that you don't run it nearly enough to
keep a defense off balance but
they need to go back to the lab and ask
themselves
are we teetering on the brink of just
going
going back to how we used to be prima
homes
or are we really going to be able to
sustain this greatness where we are in
the afc
championship game every year that this
guy's our quarter yeah
no i i mean that's the million-dollar
question
uh and you know we talk about like that
great confidence they have
self-confidence that each player and all
that i do think that got them in trouble
in the super bowl i do
you know a gift in the curse right that
whole like thing there
yeah their great confidence and
cockiness and everything like that
you know you heard my homes there they
got greedy oh you know oh i'm gonna look
for big plays we kept calling big plays
to go down the field and do that even
though they were playing defenses to
stop that
you know so they definitely have to go
back to the lab mike whether that's just
infuse a little bit more running game
or something that i i don't think that's
really realistic
like like you just said i mean it's
that's not andy reid
he's not going to all of a sudden change
and go let's run it 27 times
27 times a game between the tackles and
pull go he just i don't think he's gonna
do that
so that's where i go into you're right
mike like get back in the
lab and find new ways to dissect people
in the past game a little bit like we
talked about at that time
more get another route runner to run
short routes underneath you know julian
edelman style wes welker style
have something like that paired along
with kelsey and clyde edward solaire
coming out of the back field and doing
that
with now you got tyrique and nicole
hartman to stretch the field
but i do think they have to find a new
approach and you know mike you bring up
the patriots too right and the
motivation and the thing like that
the one thing i'll say you know when it
comes to being like
successful year in and year out and all
of those type of things
you you got to be into yourself you got
to self scout your you can't be
motivated by everybody else every week
right
there's got to be like what are we doing
better we're going to compete against
ourselves and we're going to get better
we have this flaw we got to fix that
that was something that really jumped
out to me in new england in my time
there
there wasn't no much like bulletin board
material it was more like
wait we did this last week and we got to
fix it
this week to be better and i think there
is something to that
in fact of being able to stay on top of
the mountain for a long time
i think the flaw in kansas city the
biggest flaw is that
because patrick mahomes is so special
right
and so skilled and so able to pull a
rabbit
out of his hat or some other orifice
like he did with that jet
chip wasp play in super bowl 54
when it looked lost when they're down 10
with seven minutes to go against the
49ers
i feel like too often the chiefs are
just kind of waiting around
from a home magic yeah instead of being
more
proactive about making things work well
if all else fails patrick will save our
ass
well sometimes yes sometimes no
sometimes you got to help him and you
just can't wait for him to make magic
especially when he's running around on
a bad foot and he's got backup offensive
lineman and we're not doing anything to
help
yeah the offensive lineman buy time for
him
he can't make magic under those circles
speaks to your point i mean
that's two i mean mike i think you just
you kind of just explained it right
there
they went into the that game that super
bowl game
yeah one was like not getting into the
lab and having a different
you know approach the game together all
together but i think you're exactly
right
they went into that game going wait yeah
their front four is awesome
and yeah they sacked aaron rodgers and
you know that good offensive line in
green bay
a few times but we got my homes he'll
he'll dance and move and figure it out
and
trying to some way you're right i think
it it was part of their
their cockiness and their casual
approach to the game a little bit was
hey we haven't lost a game in a long
time
we got my homes and we're gonna do what
we do
to win a football game but as we see
there's always kryptonite and every
every team you know for the nfl and they
ran into it
and really what he's doing right here
watching these clips well it really is
it really is unbelievable it's
noticeable it really is
a noticeable limp and like kristen i
wanted to know if you could go back to
like
this is how bad you know he's hurt one
of the first highlight packages we
showed today
he was on the ground in that game and he
was looking
he put his hand up because he was
looking for one of the bucks to help him
up
like pick me up like because his toe was
hurting so much that he didn't
it hurt to get off the ground but it's
amazing just watching it there right
you know right again he's truly a magic
man
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports